[Applause]
can they
[Applause]
we sets up Carter a deep
your absence does they get probably
coincide
they didn't have cable backward learners
from the yeah he wants to convince
Congress just will not go away Carter
talk to hi glass
[Applause]
and or cigarettes
[Applause]
they got the initial and by Vince Carter
[Applause]
through jury against Tenace Vince fakes
drives
just beat along over the top of the tier
right now he is able to exist and AM and
finish with the beautiful does it so
well
Randolph against Georgian my speed is to
Carter Carter gets the bucket
Clippers Maya pair the defensive end of
the floor and offensively outside he
holds takes two threes
Vince just great patients out there
Kevin the pump-fake saw the meds smaller
guys have played together longer and
they understand what they're trying to
get accomplished harder off the bench
with a hoop and the harm convinced with
six points last night against Houston at
time go right to the basket misfire tap
out rebound Carter
[Applause]
[Music]
the naked eye I thought he got it off in
time and sure enough he did with plenty
of time
Vince Carter couldn't get the weak side
rebound there's these we'll get it back
on 24 second possession and then a knock
away as Vince Carter collides with
McCallum Connelly with a dunk
Zach Randolph was doing himself Chalmers
on the pitch out Vince for three tango
and a timeout taken by Bret brown you
don't want to go underneath too many
blue and scream to get those good looks
from the perimeter
Carter start to back
the show the gold the finish
Vince checks the clock posts up steps
dude draws the foul and the bucket
how could you not be such a nice guy
he's adjusted his game to the to his
point in life
the fact that he's been the holophone
production from the grizzlies has been
fantastic tonight and bits Carter
Finch sanity rev it up to the after the
Grizzlies means that's pretty after the
Grizz shot clock down to seven to
Michael Green then he just makes right
here good thing he's a reverse slam oh
no no this is the old Vince Carter
Linsanity is in the building again he
likes to throw back Fred Vince with 11
points
[Applause]
the last shot here Vince
buthe quit his bruises team going into
the timeout / Wow Wow body shot
[Applause]
down 16 at the brain they have pulled
within five Marcus Aldridge his season
high for a single quarter this season
Vince Carter with the fadeaway hits busy
start the quarter some thought about it
shot clock down to five
Randolph calling Fort Harrison stuck in
the corner bullet pass Vince Carter
three ffensive in deflections have been
paramount and then here terrific pass
and Vince before the clock goes now the
Denver has the lead late here in the
first quarter Carter around the Randolph
screen
Vince pulls up and hits another drive
going towards the basket with Vince it's
Vince Carter here many people partners
can off the dribble for Vince Carter
[Applause]
nice pad good vision there over the
top-25 Vince Carter Randolph against
embiid
great look Carter gonna cut in a slam
this bass everybody thought it was going
back to Zach Randolph at the top of the
key but at the last minute Andrew
Harrison sees the streaking Vince Carter
whose kid
polka for against Gasol clocks Vince
Carter's that won't fall the rebound
ping-pong around here's Carter at an
industrial school
and Marcus all waving everybody to
lecture back
whose is match their largest
[Applause]
great knock away by that Randolph to
stay involved in the defensive play and
then Vince Cutler has been making
miraculous shots he could score and
score and score this
[Applause]
known as Air Canada I'm gonna spin I'm
gonna spin again
sensational by this car turns the
ageless one and another memory that he
had that many looks as good as the one
the mills just got
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it comes off that screen and able to
penetrate and you see out doing just
keeps his hands straight up he doesn't
come down with it he doesn't come down
with his hands he's allowed that space
fearless bear Tom's misses there's
Aldrich offensive board sequence
Vince Carter my goodness
bounce bounce it he may feel it tomorrow
but what a heck of an effort
[Applause]
fearless Bear Todd's misses there's
Aldrich offensive board
Oh sequence earth coming from weak side
here the market colleges had no idea he
was there and then did not give up on
the play here on Kyle Anderson to pick
up the second one to save a basket and
Rakeem Christmas she has a very good
first half there's a steal Vince Carter
[Music]
that's a better job defensively and
that's marina roll situations right
tonight he and his wife Tucker welcoming
twin girls earlier today Carter for
three it's true
and that'll do it three that went too
strong to Michael Green offensive
rebound
Vince will tee up a three the feature
Vince Carter Monroe that was ranked
three by Mike Conley got three on one if
they hurry Tony Allen Jamaica dream of
insanity and a strap to the backboard
she had great passing by this team and
Vince said oh I still have hops off of
the version slapping the backboard
afterwards monster mover reverse the
duck stop the back door for vent lock
the game clock Carter for three
[Music]
[Applause]
two tenths of a second you re minted the
third quarter will tell the tale of how
far back this team is Wow
having the plague at the shot clock a
lot in this third quarter a lot of
standing right now partner we'll try for
three
Bango a bailout triple by vin spider
this is reflected by Gordon bow now it's
part of good ball movement and Randolph
with the basket and it's a four-point
game
speaking of Isiah Thomas he's expected
to come back for the Portland game on
the second what a nice punch by
cauley-stein on the set up by court
almost to turnover
[Applause]
but it doesn't matter its Kings Bowl
Carter
[Applause]
another look Carter he's got 17
Sacramento with the lead partner got a
hand on it that's the 11th turnover
temple nobody stops a ball and he takes
it all the way Carter both Donovan
shield and Costa Koufos who's got the
ball we'll set the lineup for tempura
when they touch Vince Carter put it
behind you come back to the next night
forget about it and do it again and
we're seeing that scowl rolling on their
inbox any it's the three-ball Vince
Carter back on and make something happen
that wasn't there but how about Vince
Carter really look like he couldn't
possibly the Kings
Carter the first lead of the night for
Sacramento
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful move by Vince Carter more that
was it
big corner with a chance
to lead to one reverse lamp now much
Vince with the hands getting the ball
away from the demands I see
and as part of Palestine good ball
movement and of course Willie again
finds the open guy Vince Carter moving
well without the ball fits
oh those young legs now takes a deep 3
and then a 3 prevents Tory and Prince a
lot of pressure on him he's dribbling
the double-team came right there you see
Vince Carter from downtown New York
knocks at that just that little
hesitation gaze Feldman enough time to
get a hand on that shot
[Applause]
Fitz Carter
three Gibson Vince fires murder gets it
back to it
[Applause]
welcome to the Pantheon cook gives it
back to Kady gets into the lane comes
inside blocked by pegs in the hawk zone
working the ball around the woman best
Connor goes up
no he didn't stick his leg out actually
plate ran into his eyes they got a mouse
of the house they find him out to Carter
Vince shovels
Alex went jams Nica buck closing out the
third buried strongly and the hockey and
it is you don't even know he's out there
farther behind the back to Poythress
by the Hawks are on top of their game
here first with the finish
sliding on defense you let a guy get
that Jeep bad things happen porch was a
good public defense trouble great fine
by him
batted away bread's gets a hand on it
saves him over the Carter Vince to tray
for three lot of contact begin though
with Van Fleet
[Applause]
rejected by fence Carter
at the no call point ballgame tre was
six trade with five prey hands it over
Carter will fire 1.2 shot he about Vince
Carter and rhythm gets it back another
opportunity for the young man is Compton
play Vince what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content